almost two years since the start of the
pandemic the world is racing to contain
and understand a fast spreading and
potentially more dangerous variant of
the coronavirus on Friday a World Health
Organization panel named the variant
Omicron after it was first detected in
southern Africa it has already been
found in Belgium Israel and Hong Kong
the news prompted a wave of new
international travel restrictions
including here in the United States and
it rattled stock markets around the
world the Dow lost more than 900 points
or roughly 2 percent in a holiday
shortened session Friday and the S P 500
was down by more than 2 percent one
place was hit early in the outbreak is
South Africa Deborah patta begins our
coverage in Johannesburg
good morning Global attention is focused
here on South Africa Ground Zero for
this new variant before scientists have
been able to determine just how
dangerous this new Omicron strain is
countries have a rushed to impose tough
new travel restrictions the discovery of
the variant has sent a chill across a
pandemic weary World Omicron has over 30
mutations which scientists worry could
make it more transmissible and vaccine
resistant but amidst the heightened
anxiety there are voices of calm like
here at the Texas Children's Hospital
Center for vaccine development where Dr
Peter Hotes says there is no need to
panic it was troubling as all the
mutations in the spike protein are the
key is knowing how transmissible and
whether it has that ability to
out-compete Delta and and that bar is
high scientists are working around the
clock to determine just how bad the
variant is but a jittery world is not
waiting to find out and warnings by
global Health experts to avoid knee-jerk
responses have gone largely ignored the
U.S is joining countries in Europe and
Asia who have already closed their doors
to South Africa leaving International
Travelers frantic to get home it's
unfair it's unjustified
it's abrupt and it's not good for
tourism for South Africa South African
scientists say they are just 14 days
away from knowing how effective the
vaccines are against Omicron and both
moderna and Pfizer say if necessary they
can quickly adjust their vaccines
scientists tell us that Omicron was only
identified in South Africa because of
the country's excellent variant
surveillance and that in all likelihood
the new strain is already in many other
parts of the world for CBS Saturday
morning Deborah Potter Johannesburg